the movie starts in a luxury Yacht Where
several Rich guys are having beer and
enjoying a good time one of them is
Wallace a shrewd businessman who is
always looking to trick others for his
personal benefit after everyone leaves
he stays behind and orders some more
beers but right when the waitress Vicky
approaches him Wallace unexpectedly
begins to twist and turn then his bones
start cracking in a terrifying manner
Wallace screams for help but Vicky is
just as confused as he is no one apart
from them is present on the yacht and it
seems like an invisible force is
torturing him unfortunately all four of
Wallace's hands and legs are broken in
half much to the girl's horror after a
while two detectives Audrey and Nathan
arrive on the scene to investigate when
they take a look at the unconscious
Wallace they quickly realize that they
are dealing with something dangerous the
forensics doctor explains that all of
Wallace's appendages were broken at the
exact angle of 90 degrees Audrey is
completely baffled by the incident and
when she goes through Wallace's body she
finds a strange black substance in it no
one knows what it is or where it came
from following this the detectives
interrogate the rich owner of the ought
Captain Richards he mentions that
Wallace had a lot of enemies because of
his cunning attitude but there was no
one on the deck except the waitress when
the incident occurred Richards further
explains that his yacht is one of the
most luxurious ones around with Cutting
Edge technology so a mechanical
malfunction is completely out of the
question once his interrogation is over
the detectives said to Vicki who is
still in a State of Shock her dad Alec
and fiance Jimmy are also there Alec
reveals that he also works on the yacht
and when the incident took place he was
in the maintenance room meanwhile Jimmy
believes that it is the doing of
something Supernatural shortly after the
detectives learned that another man has
been killed in a gruesome manner when
they arrive at the scene they find his
corpse shredded in perfectly aligned
pieces as if he was measured and cut
with a scale one of the cops on the
scene reveals that the victim is Joe
santamaro a dishonest and rude real
estate agent he was working in his
office as usual when something suddenly
took over him causing him to scream in
pain when halp arrived Joe is already
dismembered and lifeless this puzzles
the detectives and when Audrey inspects
the office she once again finds the
black substance nearby Detective Nathan
concludes that the culprit behind both
the murders is the same one because both
the victims were he also
assumes that the Killer is using some
sort of telekinesis to carry out his
activities meanwhile we learned that
Alec was once again in the proximity
when the murder took place believing
that he is the murderer the detectives
interrogate him angrily and demand an
explanation Alec nervously reveals that
he had visited Joe to sell his house but
the deal never went through to test
whether he is telling the truth Audrey
starts cursing at him hoping that he
will use his telekinesis powers on her
and expose himself however he only gets
angry and does nothing hence proving
that he is not the culprit in the next
scene the lab results finally come out
and the black substance is revealed to
be charcoal this is the same type of
charcoal that is found in sketch pencils
with this clue the detective said to the
local stationery to investigate Nathan
approaches the storekeeper and inquires
if anyone bought charcoal pencils
recently the woman mentions that a lot
of people buy those every day making it
impossible to find the culprit upset the
detectives exit the store and start
listing the possible suspects Audrey
believes that Vicky's fiance Jimmy might
be the one behind it as he also works on
the yacht and is often mistreated by the
rich guy perhaps he is taking revenge on
all of them using his voodoo magic
Nathan finds this hard to believe but
nonetheless he decides to help Audrey
interrogate the boy later the two
approach the yacht while a sniper
overlooks them from a distance the
latter has been ordered to immediately
shoot Jimmy if he starts using his
telekinetic Powers soon the detectives
begin the interrogation and request
Jimmy to honestly tell whatever he knows
about the murders you've been buying
pencils lately you piece of he
agrees but just as he is about to reveal
something he feels a sharp pain in his
face then an eerie sound starts coming
from inside his body just like the one
Wallace made before he was broken in
half the next second Jimmy's eyes and
mouth are erased from his face shocking
the detectives who are right next to him
this proves that even he is not the
killer or maybe that he bought erasers
instead later we see Jimmy receiving
medical attention at the police station
despite his critical condition he is
still alive for the time being however
Audrey knows that if they don't catch
the killer more people will die soon so
she makes it her ultimate mission to
catch him and kick his ass after a while
the detectives decide to interrogate the
final person who is associated with the
yacht Vicky coincidentally she is also
an arts teacher who usually buys
charcoal pencils from the stationary
Nathan and Audrey arrive outside her
classroom and request a minute with her
however Vicky appears to be scared and
wants nothing to do with them she also
inadvertently reveals that her dad has
been missing for two days the detectives
try to coerce her for more information
but she slams the door on them and
leaves with no options left Nathan and
Audrey side to break into her house to
find Clues when they reach the garage
they are taken aback to find hundreds of
sketches and paintings scattered on the
floor on the wall many of them have been
ripped off it is evident that someone
hurriedly took away all the sketches
right then a Voz breaks inside the room
scaring the detectives Audrey assumes
that the wind was responsible for it but
Nathan says it is not possible as all
the windows are closed maybe you farted
says Audrey then as they scan through
the house Audrey shockingly discovers a
sketch of Nathan and when she playfully
Taps on it Nathan is thrown away and
bashed against the wall this finally
reveals how the murders and attacks are
being carried out or maybe Nathan just
farted again Audrey deduces that
Wallace's sketch was probably folded
because of which his bones got shattered
Joe's sketch was shredded causing his
whole body to tear into pieces and as
for Jimmy his face was erased with an
eraser meanwhile Nathan picks up a
sketch from the floor which turns out to
be of the same Voz that was destroyed
earlier he then explains that not only
people but objects are also affected by
this magic it is then revealed that
Nathan had accidentally stepped on the
sketch earlier which caused the vas to
shatter into pieces Nathan then draws a
bigger penis onto his sketch in the next
scene Wallace regains Consciousness and
the detective immediately confronts him
for the answers although weary Wallace
mentions that he doesn't have many
enemies but the one person who could put
him in this situation is Captain
Richards this is because he owed him a
massive three million dollars shocked
Audrey inquires if the other victim Joe
is also related and Wallace explains
that he was a good friend of Richards he
was actually the personal realtor of the
entire group of friends just then Audrey
gets a call from one of her Juniors
informing her that Vicki has been
spotted near the beach so the detectives
wasted no time and rushed to the scene
only to find Vicky making another sketch
this time she is carefully sketching a
villa which is positioned right next to
the beach Nathan angrily asks her why
she's doing all of this but Vicky
pretend depends as if she knows nothing
however when the detectives continue
forcing her she breaks down and finally
reveals that she's doing all this to
save her father it turns out Captain
Richards is The Mastermind behind this
he has kidnapped her father and is using
her magic sketches to take revenge on
all the people that have betrayed him
Nathan curiously asks how he got to know
of her sketches to which she responds
that her fiance proudly told him about
them Vicki further explains that
currently she is making the sketch of
The Villa on the orders of Richards he
warned her to submit it by 5 PM or else
he would kill her father hearing this
Audrey puts two and two together and
finally realizes that Richards wanted
the money from Wallace so he could buy
The Villa when the latter couldn't
provide the funds he was attacked
brutally as for Joe he was killed
because he couldn't get Wallace's
favorite Villa meanwhile Vicky says that
she tried making a new sketch of
Richards to kill him but it turns out
that only the first sketch Works
currently Richards has all of her
sketches locked up in his yacht to make
matters worse he even has a sketch of
King's Point
Hill station from which the entire city
can be seen if Richard crumples it even
a bit the city will be hit by a massive
earthquake elsewhere at the Yacht a wine
Smuggler named Duke meets Richards with
some of his best collection the latter
is instantly impressed and he orders
Duke to store the wine in his Cellar
just then the detectives also arrive and
confront Richards for all the crimes
that he has committed at first he plays
innocent saying that he only sells fish
but when the detectives list out his
entire operation Richards gets angry he
then brings out the sketch of the entire
city threatening to tear it in half just
when it appears as if all hope is lost
Richard suddenly gets hit by an
invisible force causing him to drop the
sketch to everyone's surprise Duke comes
out of the cellar with Richard's
original sketch in hand it turns out he
is Audrey's good friend and she had
hired him to carry out the operation
Vicky's dad is also rescued and they
finally reunite after days apart
meanwhile Richard's sketch falls into
the sea and starts getting wet causing
water to come out of his face Nathan
hurries to fetch it out but it is too
late the sketch sinks into the sea and
with this Richards also dies a gruesome
death in the final scene we see Vicky as
re-sketched her fiance's face and he is
recovering well the city's death mystery
is finally solved but no one knows how
the sketches were able to perform such
magic regardless Vicky promises that she
will never buy charcoal pencils again
people say Hitler became evil because he
was a failed painter but if this story
taught us anything it's that even
successful artists can be Pricks
subscribe for more videos like this turn
on notifications and leave a like to
help the channel out thank you for
watching